This weekend I went to Oklahoma
to catch fish with my bare hands.
Role the tape.
(audience chuckling)
What?
(country music playing)
All right, I'm here with Jackson
and Skipper and they are the hosts of
you tell 'em.
Well, Hillbilly Handfishin'.
Tell me the idea of the show.
Well, we pretty much just, uh,
take city slickers and offer
'em to the gods for bait.
And tell the people how hot it is.
Oh, it's a hundred and,
probably 118 right now.
118 right now.
In other words, we're all stupid.
(audience laughing)
We're gonna slip up over here, real easy.
Nice and easy so we don't spook anything
and they're not even
gonna know we're there.
Okay
Skipper and I are so quiet,
you're not even gonna be able to hear it.
So I'm gonna have to keep
my big trap shut. All right.
This is it.
This is what you've been
trained for, right here.
Let's go. I haven't been trained at all.
(twangy harmonica music)
(audience laughing)
This is what we're doing?
[Skipper] This is it.
Get right down in here.
[Andy] All right.
Sidle up next to this brush.
Use your hands, feeling
from the bottom up.
This is, this is ridiculous.
(audience laughs)
Everyone who told me I was stupid
for doing this is exactly right.
(audience laughs)
[Skipper] Fish right here. Comin' to ya.
(water splashing)
They're both gone. Let's get out of here.
(audience laughing)
(gurgling)
Imagine where his tail is at
and then stick your hand
over in front of his face
And have him bite my fingers.
No, you'll, it'll stop him.
Okay.
Lemme see if I can...
And at what point do I shriek like a girl?
(audience laughing)
No, no. Underwater.
Always underwater.
Now that we're in murky water together,
I feel like there's no secrets between us.
No. There shouldn't be.
No. No.
In fact, you know what, Jackson?
In all the years I've been in TV,
right now is the first
time I've ever been peeing
while on TV.
(audience laughing)
You be looking for
snakes, if you don't mind?
I don't mind at all.
But there's a camera.
I can't help but look at the camera.
(audience chuckles)
Snake, camera, snake.
I can't decide.
(country guitar twang)
Oh, you're back? How was it?
(audience laughing)
Real thick in there.
[Andy] Yeah, yeah.
We'll stand right here,
everybody bein' quiet.
We'll give him a little shot,
a little better shot than all
Right.
Of us cobbling in the water.
[Andy] It's not us. It's all these people.
My entourage.
(audience laughing)
I wish I could get 'em up.
But, you know...
That's life in hip-hop.
(audience laughs)
[Jackson] Feel that? Feel that?
Feel where I have my hand?
Uh huh. And that's his mouth?
[Jackson] Yes. You gotta
get your hand on his mouth.
[Skipper] Over here, Andy.
Come right to me.
[Jackson] Easy, easy. Keep comin'.
Oh!
[Jackson] Don't go nowhere.
Come here, come here, come here.
Come on. Come on back. Come on back.
Now, this is, this is the second time
I've been peeing on television.
(audience laughing)
[Jackson] And then, I mean,
you've got to squeeze hard
and bring him to your belly button.
Squeeze hard! Squeeze hard!
(audience gasping)
You got him?
Oh yeah!
(audience cheering)
Oh! Oh!
Monster! Monster catfish.
It's your hands that are so big
that's makin' this fish look small, Andy.
Is that what it is?
[Skipper] You're hands are so big.
That's a 40 pound fish.
(Andy laughing)
If this is a 40 pound fish, I weigh 210.
(audience laughs)
Should I let him go?
Yeah. You gotta give him a kiss.
It's Oklahoma tradition.
All right.
(kissing sound)
Bye.
(audience chuckles)
[Jackson] Andy, welcome
to the brotherhood.
Thank you.
You have done...
I've done something that Taylor Swift
is gonna do next week.
(audience laughs)
All right. Good start. Good start, guys.
(country guitar music)
Big fish! Big fish!
(splashing)
(yelling)
Don't nobody move!
[Woman Off Camera] It's
goin' back that way.
Snake! Snake!
Oh, come on.
All right. All right. Come on.
There's a big fish in there.
(audience laughing)
[Together] Oh!
Oh! Woo!
(audience laughs)
(Andy laughing)
[Skipper] Andy, why didn't you catch him?
There he goes! There he goes!
Somebody went underneath
me at the same time.
I was scared about the one underneath
because it was right near
a very sensitive area.
(audience laughing)
I just had to...
Oh! (beep) It hit me!
(audience laughing and clapping)
Come here boy! Sit down on your knees.
Sit down on your knees and lean back.
Spread your legs.
Let him come between ya and mash his head
to the bottom when he comes.
(suspenseful music)
[Andy] You mean, you mean
trap him by my genitals?
Yeah. Yeah.
That's an awesome idea.
[Skipper] He's comin'. He's comin'.
Guide him to... guide him to my leg.
Let him come. Let him come.
Get your hand on the right
(loud splashing)
Right here! Right here!
Here he comes!
(loud splashing)
Got him?
(water splashing)
Hang on to him, son!
Here we go! Here we go!
Get it! Get it! Get it!
(audience laughs)
(cheering)
Get a hand in his mouth!
Yes!
(victorious music)
[Skipper] Pick him up! Pick him up!
That's a belly flop.
I believe that was the belly flop he used.
Woo!
Yes sir! All right!
Can I, can I go home now?
(audience laughs)
Oh, you want a bigger one than that.
No! This is...
I'm very modest.
Look, Conan.
Look what I did!
(audience laughs)
Barehanded!
Ha ha!
(audience cheers)
(victorious music)
(audience clapping)
(cheering)
Very nice job!
Thank you.
Very nice job.
[Andy] Thank you.